er sitzt jetzt ein präsident der sich
mit händen und füßen einer macht
festhält der hat nicht wer diesen
wahlausgang nicht akzeptieren will der
wähler öffentlich eine rede hält
zumindest bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht geplant und in idar eingesteht
noch was eigentlich üblich ist seinen
herausforderer den konkurrenten anruft
und ihm sozusagen das ist nämlich immer
der erste schritt in einem telefonat
seine glückwünsche überbringt und ihm
nur das beste wünscht und ihn dann eben
auch hilft in dieser phase des übergangs
jetzt kann man sagen schon beiden weiß
zum glück was grob auf ihn zukommt im
weißen haus denn er war dort acht jahre
als vizepräsident tätig aber dennoch ist
es eigentlich das gehört zum guten ton
kann man so sagen dass der scheidende
präsidentin sein nachfolger gesucht so
einfach und so einfach wie möglich zu
machen und auch so angenehm wie möglich
diesen wechsel daneben vorzunehmen und
das ist denke ich mal bei donald trump
nicht zu erwarten
das ist definitiv nicht zu erwarten
carina man hört nach mal die gruppe
gerade hinterm ja es wird hier immer
lauter mit jeder minute wird es lauter
und vorjahr und die stimmung steigt
sehen es auch wirklich ich versuche
jetzt trotzdem noch mal vielleicht hörst
du mich also bedürfen wirklich nicht
erwartet dass donald trump da jetzt gute
miene zeigen wird und das machen wird
was bei einer übergabe normal ist denn
wir haben es gerade erfahren donald
trump nimmt dieses wahlergebnis nicht an
ist krass war aber natürlich irgendwo zu
erwarten gerade was auch in den letzten
tagen und stunden passiert ist was kann
jetzt im schlimmsten fall passieren
carina dürfen wir uns das wirklich
bildlich so vorstellen dass im januar
ausgetragen werden muss aus dem weißen
haus was denkst du also im zweifel
müssen natürlich alle mittel dann in
bewegung gesetzt werden aber also ich
denke mal die ersten schritte werden
jetzt erst mal die sein dass das team um
ihn herum da gibt es ja wie gesagt diese
verschiedenen lager es gibt die anwälte
die nach wie vor versuchen händeringend
beweise zu finden für diese haltlosen
behauptungen die der präsident in den
letzten tagen und auch schon wochen
aufgestellt hat und immer noch da so
diesen juristischen weg einzuschlagen
aber es gibt eben auch die aus dem lager
eher vernünftig die einfach einsehen
dass es keinen sinn da hat sich an der
macht festzuklammern und die eben auch
schon in den letzten stunden auf den
präsidenten eigen geredet haben und
versuchen ihnen einfach davon zu
überzeugen jetzt noch so halbwegs wurde
von diesen abgang zu gestalten so weit
dass jetzt noch möglich ist
aus den beiden team hat man ja in den
letzten tagen eben auch schon sehr wenig
muss man sagen gehört aber das wenige
was dann kommuniziert wurde also
beispielsweise ein statement das besagte
der diese regierung verfügt über kräfte
die dem präsidenten auch wenn er
sozusagen nicht freiwillig gehen will
dann sehr höflich aus dem weißen haus
exportieren können uns in meinen worten
zu sagen also wenn er nicht freiwillig
gehen will dann wird er halt irgendwie
gegangen
also man stellt sich da glaube ich auf
alles ein im lager von beiden harris was
man auch hörte war dass sie in den
letzten tagen eben versucht haben ihre
fühler auszustrecken nicht nur natürlich
in der eigenen partei sondern auch
richtung republikaner die töne wurden
immer lauter eben auch aus den aus der
republikanischen partei die eben gesagt
haben es ist ein vollkommen normaler
vorgang dass stimmen ausgezählt wurden
abgegebene stimme stimmen ausgezählt
werden also wenn die dann immer noch
irgendwie wähler aufweisen dinge falsch
eingetragen sind und sie deswegen
ungültig sind dann ist es was anderes
aber
mal werden sie ausgezählt und diese
stimmen wurden immer lauter in den
letzten tagen eben auch bei den
republikanern und möglicherweise hatte
da auch beiden so etwas mit zu tun weil
eben er und sein team im hintergrund
versucht haben da allianzen zu spüren
dass man eben parteiübergreifend sich
jetzt mein hinter diese wahl und die
legitimität die rechtmäßigkeit dieser
wahl stellt und da einfach die zweifel
auszuräumen die der präsident auf der
anderen seite in den letzten tagen und
wochen geführt hat mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren